[Music]
the season is so good it is the
best season so far it's gonna be like
the joy that we need in this evil moment
in history welcome to America
we had infused this new tone throughout
the season to reflect what happened in
the election and so we were going to be
saying his name and talking about it
because we felt like these characters
they're gonna be talking about it and
dealing with it just like we are and it
also felt right to just not say his name
you know we don't say anything about it
and Roy gross he sucks he's so hateful I
don't even want to say his name
I'm sure people some people hate them
bleeping his name yeah I just don't
think they watch the show yeah I don't
think those people want to see two women
be like gnarly they don't want to see
two women wrong yeah get me back to New
York where everybody hates Donald my
name's Angela Clark I'm the production
designer broad city a really fun idea
that Ilana had was to do a headboard out
of protest signs and stickers I also put
some protest posters in you know just as
if like they went and protested and then
they like kept the signs you know
anything anti you don't know New York is
totally different in the winter and the
summer interesting how many different
coats you can wear at once the winter is
intense it's a dark time we were missing
a whole other side of the city can we
put the top back up
when you have a good night in the winter
in New York you're like so grateful
because you're just like mostly just
working and drinking and drinking just
makes you more depressed horrible we
deal with winter depression which is
very real every winter
Oh winter and fall and like the end of
summer too oh well I want to do one more
like small
we've wanted to experience directing
it's awesome we're each directing to
really is like this final puzzle pieces
clicking in you have to be in the scene
as an actor but also conscious of the
whole scene as a director so it's
different but I really like it so far
whether we're in the scene or not the
other person is always in video village
making sure the scene goes the way we
want are like giving pitches or thoughts
and Lily burns one of our executive
producers we have such a shorthand with
her so if we're both on screen and one
of us is directing Lily is this like a
set of eyes that is like one of us it's
it's awesome you know talking about
Leanne okay there is this Easter egg of
a joke and we walk into this karaoke bar
to follow this guy
there's a man singing a song that's
godly an
[Music]
it is a song that we made up and our
music supervisor Matt effects produced
[Music]
we're all oh my god and it plays
throughout the entire season on the
radio in cabs it plays the entire smush
rooms when Abby's like changing the
music I'm like nervous it goes
[Music]
yeah
oh yeah we are kick me put your
foot in my goddamn you
know start again this is such a dream
come true
working with RuPaul Charles was such a
dream I think the character is warm
Stern than Bruce Lee is containing him
into the manager of a restaurant I've
been watching RuPaul on TV fer my entire
life oh I'm so sorry it's always great
to see the evolution with women in
comedy
it's so exciting working with these
women I studied her as a kid and a
comedy nerd
she kept throwing in like surprising
improv she's amazing as fate would have
it today we have Shania Twain as a guest
man I feel like smoothie she was so
funny
she was so down to play with herself as
an icon she like rips this song as a
spark you gotta write it down now don't
hide it oh such a Chandler I'm so
delicious little Gunther also Trey
Parker is the lead character on broad
city
the show obviously is about a trainer
and his life and struggles and yeah it's
a show I think that shows what life is
like in New York for a healthy fifth man
to women he knows he threw a glass bowl
in a traffic fire done a diner and I
started you know it was sort of like
first wave of post-feminist
ideas and comedy and doing work that was
not self-deprecating that was not cliche
each generation takes it to another
level it's really impressive and
important and exciting it's good to see
just how they grow as there's a feeling
on the set that you feel free you feel
safe so it's a pleasure being here it
means a lot to people and I think it's
cool to have two women who are just
hilarious
crushing the comedy game it's great
because the show is written by a small
group of us who are really close and who
are all friends and I think when people
watch the show one of the things they
like most about it is how authentic it
feels because Abena Lana are really
close friends broad city was my first
big gig you know and after that other
stuff has come but like I haven't found
a sense of family or a sense of
belonging like I do here you know I mean
my love for you is sometimes
inappropriate like you thank you
love yeah yeah I'd love you tip some
people you were just destined to be in
love with
[Music]